so let's discuss what's behind an
enlarged
prostate that could potentially affect
your urination
now it is true that when men age their
prostate actually does
enlarge and take a look at where the
prostate is located
it's a gland that wraps around this
little tube that's coming from your
urinary bladder
so as you increase the size of that
prostate it's going to shut down that
tube
and it's going to affect your ability to
urinate and so
the doctor puts you on a certain
medication like flomax an antibiotic
and maybe you'll do some blood tests and
then i'll see you in six months
but my question is what is causing
the enlarged prostate
if you take a look at all of your
hormones
they can be classified really in two
different categories
one category is called anabolic
and the other category would be
catabolic
now anabolic has everything to do with
building something
up and catabolic is breaking something
down
so when you eat food you have this
catabolic effect
all these enzymes that break down food
into
their basic building blocks amino acids
fatty acids glucose etc
and then you have all the anabolic
hormones that kick in and take these
building blocks
and make body tissue out of them and so
when the prostate enlarges
it's obvious that you have this anabolic
thing going on right
if we take a look at all the anabolic
hormones we have prolactin
which and maybe you've heard of
prolactin with women
in breastfeeding but men also have
prolactin
and if the prolactin is too high it can
definitely increase the size of the
prostate
and then estrogen itself can increase
the size of the prostate
and estrogen also increases the release
of prolactin
so then you have other hormones like dht
which is a very powerful form of
testosterone
and androgens cortisol growth hormone
igf number one which is kind of the
extension of growth hormone
it's made by the liver it's stimulated
by growth hormone
definitely will increase the prostate
and you have progesterone
and insulin which is a very powerful
anabolic hormone and so let's take a
look here
what food or thing
has the majority of these hormones that
you
might be consuming on a regular basis
milk milk is a very powerful anabolic
substance that is turned into cheese
yogurt kefir and milk contains
the majority of these anabolic hormones
and so if you have urination problems or
your prostate is enlarged
you need to get off milk and milk
products 100 percent okay that's number
one
now number two is insulin what triggers
insulin
sugar a high carb diet so if your
prostate is enlarged
or you have urination problems you need
to get off sugar
and go on a ketogenic plan if you're new
to my channel
i put a link down below and then we have
estrogen
okay so estrogen can come from many
different sources
soy is a big source of estrogen so if
you're consuming anything like
soy milk or soy protein isolates
as a protein and maybe a diet shake that
you're taking
or you're not consuming organic foods
you just have commercial vegetables or
commercial foods
which have a lot of chemicals that mimic
estrogen
that could be one big factor that's
increasing the size of your prostate
now a lot of times people take natural
remedies for the prostate like
salt palmetto and because salt palmetto
inhibits a certain enzyme
that is normally converting testosterone
into a very powerful form of
testosterone
called dht which can increase the
prostate but here's the problem
if you're taking salt palmetto on top of
consuming a lot of milk products
eating on sugar potentially consuming
some soy
it's not going to work so i recommend
cut out the dairy get on a keto plan
make sure you don't consume anything
that can stimulate
estrogen in addition to that take some
salt palmetto
green tea is a great inhibitor of this
enzyme
so are pumpkin seeds zinc
and lycopene now lycopene
also has some great research that can
help shrink the prostate
and that would be high in tomatoes so
tomatoes would be a good food
to consume if you have an enlarged
prostate
so if you're going to tail or make a
diet to someone with an enlarged
prostate
not only healthy keto and intermittent
fasting
but i would also consume more
cruciferous vegetables especially kale
because that's going to help balance
your estrogen and even beats
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below check it out and get
signed up today